Smee chests on the garlic bread species
on the garlic bread Smee chests on the
garlic bread speeches on the garlic that
good morning counselor autist me chest
Italian campers here today today's the
Italian show I think Italian camper
would wear this shirt right yeah it's
kind of Italian I got it in Israel which
is nicer to Italy than here okay
European fashions okay you know the
crazy thing about Israel is is that most
content oh yeah but you know Asia
continent when you say it's in Asia it's
actually on the border of Asia Africa
and Europe no but it is in Asia that's
like a fact that I know for sure but
like it could be in any so it's more
European than American camera is well
you've any thought about this no that's
something that I learned like once in
geography class I would enjoy a fee
class edits in Asia cool okay I didn't
know that that was the decision we all
made that was the decision but it could
have been in any continent okay
any of the three not Australia not
obviously Australia anybody's welcome
back to the show thank you for having me
great again here two days in a row now
we don't need to like catch up get to
know one another now he's just like
right into it yeah we look like almost
like we're sisters or young learn camper
almost how are things going for you how
was studying yesterday tart sure but
whatever that was Theo did he make it
better he did make it better except he
is now like making me like study in my
bed which is never good no I mean I
can't [ __ ] where you eat right but he
just like wants to lay in bed like in
between my legs yeah like I have to give
him what he wants but he's been great
except for today he woke me up at 8 a.m.
when my alarm is set for 9:15 he was
being so annoying like just standing by
my bedroom door just being like and I
like perfect right but like I wasn't
prepared for the kid perfect just yet
like I needed another hour of sleep
understand that was the deal him and I
had made you know got it is he learning
a lot while you guys are studying
together
yeah for sure too bad you're not in like
a doctoral program or else he could be
teaching you know for sure he'd be like
with his classes being like he's so cute
well anyways welcome back to the morning
toast it is a beautiful Wednesday
a shockingly beautiful Wednesday finally
the weather is turning around I mean
it's a give and take because nice
weather means worse allergies but you
know what I prefer it other than the
doom and gloom of the past few days you
do mean it's nothing just doing gloom
it's been non-stop raining like I hate
rain I'm okay with cold but I'm not okay
with rain and it's really just like
ruins things for me I expect that rain
in April april showers bring May flowers
but we're in May so what's the excuse
you know yeah I don't also like campus
is really around the corner so the
weather now is now I'm think every day
that I see the weather I'm like okay
what does this mean for camp toes
because well because the weather now I
think like someone posted the weather
like for in a million days from it like
for in for webcam toes weekend I'm sorry
for one campus weekend isn't any
supposed to rain but like I don't I
don't know whether that when it's two
weeks out like how does he know that I
don't trust the weatherman uh but now
this does bode better but you know what
last time we had camp toes it rained the
entire time and there's snow you had an
incredible time so worst-case scenario
it rains we plan into our activities and
it's still lit and that's actually more
lit cuz like when you're indoors you're
drinking more when you're outside you're
distracted with all the activities right
um so I'm not worried but it would be
nice to have like a little bit of nice
weather because it's so beautiful and
you know even if the weather's bad you
just use your Jackie O flow presets
which I'm just gonna take a minute to
talk about again today because yesterday
you know everyone was loving their
presets um I'm doing I'm explaining all
of it because so many people I didn't
realize I've never used presets before
it's a position to get understands are
in the position that I was in back in
October like what is this preset what do
I pack for this preset so I've just been
explaining it I came up with a really
good analogy for presets okay my I've
had yeah
flippin inciting a filter like an
Instagram filter which it looks like a
dirty treasure map is a band-aid for a
wound you know you just like cover it up
and you know it's okay okay a preset is
surgery for the wound stitches like
really fixing the issues internally
because you know yeah yeah okay yeah
okay yeah it's like so intricate I just
needed an analogy and I think that's the
one like a filter you slap it on you
cover it up but with a preset you're
going into the photo and you're editing
of things that are wrong with it I guess
that's true actually
thanks surgery thank you so if you want
to perform surgery on your
head to jackieo flow dot-com and
everything's there for you and if you're
still having issues downloading them
reach out you know where to find your
girl you know I'm everywhere like you
know that song Hashem is here Hashem is
there Hashem is truly everywhere for her
what today okay well are you okay enough
to get into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
okay we have some really fun stories I
mean also have some shows that we're
gonna recap some of the stories will
read back will relate back to the shows
that we will be recapping okay you watch
The Bachelorette I did I think fantastic
seasonal talk and I'm going to allow you
to speak about it because I saw a few
comments about people who wanted to hear
them you really should watch it like
this is not the one that you shouldn't
watch I'm telling are you kidding me you
say after freakin Colton juice at their
location okay you sat through re you saw
through Nick vile even though we made up
made up with him wasn't great see I love
Nick's girls okay but you will like this
I'm telling you just watch the first
episode just watch the first episode
it's on Hulu for an hour and a half no
commercials we'll see we'll see I'm not
convinced yet but we'll see first story
Paris Hilton was on watch what happens
live last night first of all she was
incredible beautiful epic perfection
like I was so nervous to see she was her
first time I watched it up in live and I
was like nervous for how she was gonna
be because like people who are like so
fun you expect so much from them the
chair and then it's like hard to deliver
they only get so many opportunities to
talk and she was with Erika Jayne it's
like is there something too much of a
good thing I was really nervous but it
was great they had like mutual Queen
respect for each other that's right she
calls Lindsay Lohan quote lame and
embarrassing honestly yeah last night
she played plead the fifth because it
was her first time in the clubhouse and
for the first question and he said you
have had like public disputes with
Lindsay Lohan
say three nice things about Lindsay
Lohan so she was like she was so pressed
and she was like Lindsay Lohan is beyond
and everyone's like oh okay that's like
not yeah she though hand is beyond
layman embarrassing that that is so
sloshed it was so severe it was so funny
and I mean at this point like I don't
know what they used to fight about back
in the day probably like boys and
whatnot but at this point like Lindsay
Lohan is really embarrassing
blaming embarrassing like what
world is going on with her yes like it
seemed every time she's called him to do
something like she happens to show up
but like there's something amiss oh
there's something really a mess there so
yeah it was Sivaji actually want to
watch that it was really good and then
the other feeds with this were hmm what
were the other ones oh one there was a
rumor that she had made out with Miley
and a club in Miami once true or false
and she said she like smiled and said
maybe so it's completely true right like
that's crazy yeah and then I forget what
the second question was but anyways it
was just a really good show and I was so
impressed by her she looked so pretty
she's so pretty like what is she doing
to her face no I she's not aging she's
Benjamin buttoning oh there was a
question about Kim something about what
was your fight about back in the day or
whatever and she was just like him and I
are old school like whatever it was like
where did she leave the face at all know
which like some of her answers she like
didn't really like yeah you know
whatever but it's cool when they when
they don't plead the fifth but the trick
to pleading the game is the first
question is always the hardest but you
don't want to use your plate the fifth
because you're worried about the next
questions but it's actually the worst
question so is that like a fact now that
everybody knows yeah Andi has said it so
if you're ever like find yourself on
watch what happens right next week
actually that's good to know for you it
was a really fun episode Erica like it
was just it was great and I'll talk
about Beverly Hills what are my thoughts
what happened Oh craziness I mean not
craziness until the last minute where
Lisa Vanderpump volunteers to take a lie
detector test in the same outfit she was
wearing the day before fishy and the
same house like she's been wearing a lot
like she was also wearing an Amanda
pearls I'm hoping it's all the same day
it was very Jones black belt white
t-shirt and a light blue sweater around
her neck like she's a Stepford wife I
feel like there has to be the same day
yeah I don't believe you're on TV and
filming why would you wear this right
and she has many a sweater she could
wear everything else the same and just
changed the sweater so we'll get to that
okay next story this is a drama that has
been plaguing a lot of celebrities and
now it's hit ariana grande oh yeah
ariana grande sued over sweetener
Instagram pics ariana grande is being
sued in Manhattan federal court over
photos she posted on Instagram to
promote her sweetener album new
york-based photographer Robert Barbara
claims the $25 pop princess violated
copyright laws by
to photos he took of her to her
Instagram account August 17th 2018 the
day her album was released the snap
showed the thank you next singer
strolling out of a building carrying a
bag that read sweetener they racked up
almost 4 million likes barbara assuming
for either the prophet's crime they
earned from the photos or $25,000 from
each pic okay well two things profit Oh
like problem album profit that she had
from those photos that's that's
impossible to prove but I saw take a
seat I saw a tweet that Arianna likes
that said that he like posted on his
Instagram and said for the record I'm
not suing ariana grande I'm suing a
management company for using a photo
that I took of Ariana to promote
Coachella and Ariana like that tweet so
paid chicks is either wrong no there may
be there's more to the story but how do
you explain these sweetener pics that
have nothing to do with Coachella right
maybe they got the story wrong but why
would Ariana like Ariana like that why
would she like a tweet against her
management company where'd you read that
didn't say her management company a
management company that was promoting
Coachella not her not her Coachella
performance at Coachella maybe there's
two lawsuits going on where did you read
that someone posted it in the toasters
mmm interesante well this seems to be a
pattern that's happening out happened to
Khloe Kardashian happened to Gigi Hadid
and this photographer has also sued
Versace Jordache and CBS Interactive for
using his photos I just like like I
understand like this is their job and
like this is how they make their money
you but like suing someone for posting a
photo of themselves and they have no
right to do that that makes absolutely
no sense to me yeah and it's not like an
ad the coachella thing I actually
understand is that's if that's sure that
makes sense if you're using someone's
copyrighted photo like without paying
for it to promote something sure but if
the celebrity is posting a paparazzi
photo of themselves that they like not
in an ad not pushing anything just like
happy Monday yeah yeah yeah I think it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] and think yeah you're
supposed to tag the photographer but
like say Ariana just wanted this photo
and she just googled like ariana grande
sweetener and she found it like she
doesn't know who took it like how is she
okay but if they posted in tagged the
photographer I don't even think that's
it I think that they could still sue
because they're saving someone credit
and that's a tag like we consider it
credit you know on the streets here but
in a court of law that's not nests
okay so I think this is a much bigger
issue but here's the thing paparazzi are
so invasive and really I mean I'm not
gonna like be here like talking about
how it's so hard to be a celebrity
because I don't think that it is but you
know they cause a lot of chaos a lot of
the time with major celebrities and it's
very innovative shots when they get
punched
it's very Mesa and I think from what a
lot of somebodies have said it's really
the worst part about being a summary is
the paparazzi the least that they can do
is that it's let you use the photos that
they're taking yeah you know yeah so I
don't think they have any compassion or
else they wouldn't be in that line of
business yeah that's just that's my two
cents on how do you wake up one morning
and decide I want to be a paparazzi
photographer I don't know I want to yell
at celebrities and take pictures of them
and then sue them for it I don't know
you know people just fall into something
did you wake up one morning and say I
want me snitch or I want to be a
counselor it just happened to you
because you made it happen to me yeah
honestly paparazzi's are the real
snitches they're our biggest snitches
maybe I should become a paparazzi
photographer maybe you shouldn't me and
Kendall also being paparazzi sounds like
grueling work like a lot of like
footwork you know being on your feet and
drop it out camping out and honestly
like if they're on their feet too much I
hope they're their shoes are comfortable
and they're wearing comfortable socks
much like bomb bus pops if you don't
know about bomb us it's time how often
do you think about your socks if you're
like I used to be honestly not much
always wearing mismatched socks for a
few months I wore socks that were a size
too small and they were making my
toenails ingrown I was having toenail
pain I can't because I wasn't even
wearing the right tie saw I can't tell
you the last time I wore my I wore match
socks like I never do yeah but now that
Bahamas is in my life like no more
ingrown toes and that's just the start I
recently discovered socks that changed
the way I'll think about socks forever
they are called bum bus bama's are the
most comfortable socks in the history of
feet they're made from super soft
natural cotton and every pair comes with
arch support I am personally flat footed
this is very important to me a seamless
toe also important to me now that I've
suffered and a cushioned foot bed that's
comfy but not too thick with so many
colors patterns links and styles bombas
look great in the gym at the office and
out on
town by your bombas today at bombas calm
/ toast and get 20% off your first
purchase that's B om bas calm / toast
for 20% off bombast calm / toast I can't
recommend them highly enough like I
never thought about my socks in it and
now I do and I'm better off for it yeah
yeah you're a big Bob bus fan yeah yeah
ok next story I am so obsessed with
because Bethenny Frankel has clap back
clapped back at Jason Hoppy her ex I
actually saw and his lawyer in the most
epic way so for those of you who just
need a little bit of backstory Bethenny
Frankel is constantly in court with her
ex-husband who is just allegedly a
monster and it's always drama-filled but
their recent claim is that they have
criticized her use of social media and
that she's always you know going to
social media for ballets for validation
hobbies attorney Robert Wallach asked
the Real Housewives of New York City
Star about her Instagram account in
court on Tuesday May 14th according to
Radar Online her the lawyer specifically
referenced Frankel's decision to share a
video of herself crying over the loss of
her dog cookie following a seizure in
October 2017 quote isn't it a fact that
you would rather take advice from 2
million followers than Jason wallah
casse Frankel you were looking to
exploit this tragic situation you were
doing it for attention correct the
lawyer said Franco replied no I don't
need attention while it continued to
push the issue asking the Bravo star why
do you feel the need to share your
personal life each time with your 2
million followers and then she responded
in the most epic paragraph of all time
quote I know a lot of my fans I do a lot
of book signings they help support me
and they helped me pay Jason's rent and
they're the people that are allowing me
to stand on my own two feet that's how I
made money to pay Jason millions of
dollars that's how he is paying your
legal bills that's why you have this job
right now
that's how Jason can afford his rent and
that's how I can afford my rent and
support my daughter epic epic I wonder
what the lawyer did after that he
hopefully took a goddamn seat yeah what
an [ __ ] I love I mean I love that
and you know it really is true we talked
about her social media use a lot on the
show because she is so open with her
followers and and so unfiltered like
even in the most basic sense of like not
using a filter right you know like she's
just raw her that's what I would say her
so her Instagram stories are raw and now
I totally understand I also understand
the use of social media like Gaza
business hello the morning toast but
like her feeling the need that she needs
to like share with her audience because
that is what's gotten to her to where
she is
ya know that is so epic I read that last
and that's what's got his lawyer to
where he does he even have a job
I think his job is being like a
full-time monster thirst monster as well
right but I I don't know if he has a job
when they started dating like he was
just like a Rando like in banking or
whatever you know so I don't know if
he's like continued to go back to that
what are they still in court for does he
want constant custody issues and then
with Dennis's death oh that was so fun
it as an excuse to say that that means
an unfit mother because of like the drug
use or whatever but that was thrown out
right I think so but they're but they're
still there they reach the custody
agreement over there now nine-year-old
daughter Brandon 2014 but they returned
to court after Franco sued happy for
full custody okay so she's suing for
full custody
that makes sense she previously accused
her ex-husband of emotional abuse which
he denied in March Franco compared
living with happy to being in a torture
chamber on Tuesday she claimed that she
didn't want to make an orthodontist
appointment for her daughter until after
the trial because happy would be present
I mean yeah that's the other thing it's
like not only does she have to like get
his claws out of her but like their
daughter's involved and it really is all
the things that she says that he is how
can she like let her daughter spend time
with no for sure so that's really sad
that's really sad he's a huge [ __ ]
she does I mean I'm not like the judge
or anything but like I'm team Bethenny
and she deserves full custody and she's
an awesome mom and like I say that she's
such a great mom yeah she does it all
you know and she really is supporting
like this grown man and his lawyer she
really is and like that's not enough for
him should have been enough first he's
like it wasn't ever like he got so much
from their divorce and like he's still
the only reason why we're talking about
him is because of her right damn I feel
so bad like and we don't even see this
this is like a savage and still has like
stills
able to like be like yeah but we never
we don't see any of this on the show and
you see on the show of her it's like she
goes through so much and it's like this
layer on top of it it's it's I don't
know how she deals I don't know how she
deals either she has like all these
things he has so much strength I still
have a piece of seaweed stuck in my
teeth from last night
where'd you order from I ordered from
the most disgusting pokey place I was
healthy shiny healthy
I joined me healthy so I ordered like
some okay some like tuna avocado salad
seaweed salad like you know just like
some fresh fish for the hubs and I and
it was like so disgusting like actually
my pokeballs I got I don't know there
was one spicy tuna hand roll that was
[ __ ] gnarly so that was like
definitely not fresh okay but my poke
cable was not bad except I guess this
shot the sauces they used for the spicy
tuna was not good so ruined the whole oh
yeah yeah so all of it was inaudible
except for a seaweed salad which I'm
still suffering from the whole thing was
a ginormous waste I didn't even know
that there was poke a near us anyway
it's not super close it was like just on
post mates but it was just such a waste
like and that's what I get for trying to
be healthy right
you know just stick to my Chloe yeah I
also have been eating by Chloe recently
because I'm like a big vegan apparently
and it's really good I love their veggie
meatballs
I like their guac burger I have to try
and yeah I have to try it okay well this
is a really Bravo heavy show today
because our next story and also another
slow news day but you know what I don't
mind it cuz he got the snitch and we got
to get your pulse yeah we got to just
like you know true you think you'll ever
start watching the Housewives I want to
like my heart and my head want to but
it's just like it's such a big
undertaking and it's like I'm in too
deep with not watching that I just don't
think I can but I want to yeah and you
don't watch Hannah pomp rules I think
that if anything I would start with
Vanderpump rules cuz that's one I really
wish I watched yeah well this is a
Vanderpump rules start story lalla Kent
was drunk at Disney for four days
straight with her stepkids yes I saw
this lava Ken confessed she hit rock
bottom with alcoholism
while on a family vacation with fiance
Randall Emmett and his two young
daughters London and Riley so on the
reunion Andy asked her because she is
now completely sober and he asked if
something happened to cause
to get help that night she said quote I
went with my family and Rams family to
Disney World and I was drunk four days
straight from morning until night she
told Annie Cohen I get on the plane I'm
faced chugging out of a bottle and the
next morning I woke up and said I will
never live this way again and they
reached her out and got help
the reality star shed says she's been
sober since October 22nd and added that
she will quote never she never will
drink again
Wow wish wish she an alcoholic so she is
strange now I mean an alcoholic but the
way that we've seen this unfold is on
the show she says that she had had some
experiences with her fiance well at the
time her boyfriend liked where she like
broke through like a hurricane proof
window that made her like never want to
drink again so on the show she's not
drinking but then they go on a trip and
she drinks and she's like having an
anxiety attack but so she's like either
totally not drinking or drinking got it
and it's like honestly alcohol is like a
big factor on the show we talk about it
a lot and there are a lot of people who
have like definitely problematic
relationships with alcohol and if you
looked at it on the face I wouldn't have
said that Lala was one of them but
apparently it is like a big issue for
her so on the show after that trip where
she's gonna use panic attacks she says
she's not drinking then we find out when
she was on watch what happens live that
she actually hit rock bottom way later
than that on October who's that day and
that was Disney all right Josie was this
year days me was this packed up past
October and she hasn't drank since then
oh I figured that this was like years
ago and it was just coming out now
no on the show she like just would stop
drinking and like she just said like
that's what she needed to do but after
Disney she like went and got help and
now she's like she's like a professed
alcoholic and she will never drink again
in her life she says which is like a
really mature step to take I think also
her dad had died a year ago so that she
was using alcohol and so like she was
drinking a lot but it kind of made sense
like she was leaning on alcohol but like
that it didn't necessarily speak to a
larger problem in her life like overall
yeah so I'm so proud of her
a lot of to the reunion last night was
is your iPad I think there's something
with my top side is slippery okay that's
better my jeans have traction um
the reunion last night was wild for a
season that had
solutely like little to no drama um it
was a very dramatic rhenium I can't even
deal but you know what's so crazy so I
love to just go to Twitter after an
episode of a show to see like what what
side people are by the time and you know
what every single person was on James
Kennedy side and now I'm realizing I
don't think that Twitter speaks for like
the the people anymore I think Twitter
is just like a bunch of bots and fake
accounts and some of the cast members
making their own fake accounts or like
James Kennedy or LVP Stan's making even
more accounts and it's like the people
like me who just have their opinions
like we watch the show we think about
our opinions in the meet but I like them
with your friends why don't you talk
about them early you sound like you're
insta story like I totally where you put
in the toasters I want to do a poll like
I trust the toasters opinions like I
want anyone who's watching who watched
Vanderpump rules can you just comment
and let me know if your team James or
team everyone else because like I don't
think that Twitter speaks for the people
you know I don't think to witters speaks
for the people either like I always go
and check and it's like usually take the
obvious things but it's like Twitter
harps on things that are like not what
I'm talking about is that does that make
sense it's like what I just want to see
what everyone thought about like The
Bachelor until I went to go look and
it's like they weren't even like talking
about any of the things that actually
and it's like they talk about the things
that are just like the most obvious and
dumb things I think that's interesting
like like the Starbucks cup it's like
that's what they're focusing on like
guess it became this whole big thing but
it's like why not just talk about the
pot yeah I think the game of thrones
twitter is like pretty good but there
also is so much there for like they're
you know they're gonna get it right most
of the time and also we're all pretty
much like its scripted like we're all
supposed to be like thinking the same
things but when it comes to reality TV
Twitter like I just don't think that
it's reflective of the general consensus
and something should they do those watch
what happens live polls where they like
literally ask whose side are you on
right I didn't see a poll about this but
um are those real though I think that
they're real first of all they kind of
annoy me it's like the show they Jam so
much into like the 30 minutes now I
think they'll have like premium guests
on and they're asked like a million
poles where it's like what is yeah it's
not like we're electing something like
I'm good okay everyone everyone else
someone said team James Tom and Ariana
Wow everyone else but like using
everyone else is a hypocrite
literally James called Brittany's family
Hillbillies and was talking [ __ ] about
them fast forward to the next episode
Jack says yes a very mean comment about
James's family and James walks off how
is that any different and also Jax and
James are the ones going toe-to-toe like
it's not even like Jax talk [ __ ] about
Rock Hill's family which is what James
did like I just don't understand there
are a few times where you know our
gender Carol I think so I think they
just like they work for each I don't
know I think that they're real they live
together that's as realistic that's
really um there are a few times during
this season where where I saw James side
a little bit more like even with the
Katie stuff like obviously I was team
Katie but you know what it is true like
Katie has said some nice comments about
people in the past like blah blah they
all have but they all have and it's like
Katie has made it right and apologized
and gotten to a better ground with Lala
where it's like James has no intention
of making it right so there's like
everyone just loves calling each other I
used to hook up with James they were
best friends and before they became best
friend say like we're kind of used to
flirt a little bit and I think they
hooked up once but then they were just
like best friends oh okay yeah but that
definitely like makes it weird and she's
always like that's the greatest thing
that's ever happened to you and honestly
like that is true and also like I don't
know whatever I'm seeing about Lala
these days I still have her I stand her
and I I definitely would blindly support
her even if I thought that she was wrong
but I don't think that anything she said
or done is wrong I don't know what that
says about me but I think she's allowed
to go off when she feels like it like
people have really pressed her and she
sought to fight back and I appreciate it
like I don't know if she's up for
herself but I like her he would love her
I would love her right now yeah and she
was like I've been meaning and low-key
like yelling at people with the jewel in
her hand that's like so cool so cool I
thought that jewels are cool but like
that was like totally that's like sophie
Turner there was a article about her she
always has a jewel in that if you look
in every single picture of Sophie Turner
every moment that's gone viral her
chugging the drink at the Knicks game
her just like walking down the street
with Joe apparently there was like
pictures of her literally crying in the
street with Joanna so yeah in every
single instance she has a jewel in her
hand
it like you almost missed six it's like
the size of her hand or it blends into
her phone but every single time so her
she is Julian Han even at her Vegas
wedding Oh oh my god I mean of course
and also when she was on that PJ with
Priyanka Danielle and Sophie and they'll
Instagram that they were going up
Pennsylvania for that bar like she was
like just like doing like a PG sign
right there right there's the jewel uh
also also wait sorry I won't talk myself
Eterna because like I always knew that
she was like so cool but her and Joe
lately have been like really doing it
for me like I think that they are like
the coolest couple in Hollywood I
completely agree they've been really
doing really like everything they do I'm
like wow that's so [ __ ] epic like
when they got married in baby Vegas like
I was here for it I wasn't like oh
that's weird like I was like hell yeah
two percent everything that they do like
I'm so I'm like even like when they like
like their Mecca I looked I loved them
matching I liked it wasn't my my
particular style but it was theirs and
they looked comfortable and happy and
matching and I'm sure they had a great
night oh that's the thing I always know
that they're and they look like fashion
like they're not gonna end up on any bed
so like I always have faith that like
when they go out they're having a
[ __ ] blast
oh for sure I know I'm truly have become
obsessed with the J sisters me to crank
and Priyanka Nick like here's the thing
I want to hang out with Joe and so he
like I feel like we would just all get
along so well like Nick and Priyanka
like are different they're like a little
bit more elevated you know and like
mature yeah and I don't know but I'm
just obsessed with them and I'm I'm so
on the train in such a believer in their
love no I'm so it's up Nick and Priyanka
okay so here's the thing like my [ __ ]
me a full year because the rumor started
at the mecca last year that they were
dating and it's like I laughed all the
way home for six months even when no
actually when they got married I
believed it but now not only on my
believer I am a [ __ ] Stan my opinion
has changed man they from Priyanka I'm
not a hundred percent sold just yet but
it has changed except I used to be like
when I was a Jonas Brothers fan as a
young in I was so like Nick Jonas meet
you now I'm not like when I watch him
it's like he kind of makes me cringe
like when he's on stage and like I now
bully I think that Joe is the lead
singer that's my argument okay I
musically Nick is still my favorite and
like uh sky like attractiveness I think
Nick is still the cutest I don't know
for me and also Joe I didn't realize has
an incredible voice yeah I'm on SNL and
I'm just loving the brother like the
management's decision for Kevin to lean
into being like the musical brain every
so much says I know we always like
speculated like maybe that's his role
but like now they're like giving him the
guitar solos like he's shredded he's Dan
of dan + Shay yeah yeah he he's the Tay
of Maddie and Tay oh is that the third
guy in Lady Antebellum yeah who really I
think that that guy really is the
musical guy me too like Charles and get
on the guitars it though no but like
that guys I'm like he's shredding it up
so I'm loving everything that's
happening I love the J sisters I love
the J brothers and I completely agree I
love Sophie and Jo but like I can't
believe I love making Priyanka and then
I also love that we have like a normal
couple in Kevin and Danielle and we have
like you know they are truly goals like
they have been married for a long time
we have the same wedding planner hi
Mikie Rousseau's like hopefully that
luck will rub off on me and hubs and I
think that having that like stable
relationship in the group is grounding
for everyone and necessary I'm all being
married it's like I think so cool do you
own me I love that marriage they're
making like marriage cool yeah I'm
getting gates at a young age cool yeah
and because being single has always been
cool but like being married but what's
cool doc Danielle Jonas was there like
fur it all like she was there in the
beginning like when they were dating in
like high school or whatever and they
were like blowing up and for now and
like she's probably seen some things I
want know her see her [ __ ] you know yeah
well that documentary is coming out
about the Jonas Brothers oh my god is so
good and there's a song that's playing
in the background wall like of the
trailer and I looked it up and I
couldn't find it which makes me believe
it's off of the new album and it sounds
so good and it's just oh my god I've
been like what I need this out which
drop and I need the documentary to come
out and what's so interesting it's like
they're like crying in it and stuff like
cuz Nick Jonas was like he broke up the
band and Jojo too started crying he was
like I was just so upset because it was
Nick and he's like my best friend she's
just like I get that but you know I felt
that but everything that they did they
did it right and it happen for a reason
I mean I'm the one he
like feel bad for the members of dnce
but on the other hand like they got the
ride of their lives
yeah they got an opportunity they
probably wouldn't have ever gone no like
they literally established a ban and
then the next month like they're playing
Jingle Ball like you know that doesn't
happen for most man and I'm sure now
they have it on their resume and if they
want to like join another band or
something likes to be the guitar player
because it's not like they were trying
to be the lead saying yeah and someone
was saying I think one of them was
playing on the stage at SNL like that
maybe one of them crossed over into like
the new Jonas Brothers Band but that's
like kind of sad for the other people so
I hope I mean I think there I I think I
think they're all fine also dnce songs
like are became so commercial that
they're actually like in commercials and
that's the sort of money that will last
them forever like I'm I'm not worried
about yeah they asked the DNC songs were
actually like mad good yeah they were on
like Sprint commercials yeah
do you know that the documentary is also
like one of the reasons why they even
got back together because they were
filming the documentary is just about
their past and then it got them thinking
about starting again really yeah that's
so I'm excited for the documentary which
is actually a great segue into our fifth
story about the Game of Thrones
documentary that's coming out on May 26
the last watch the trailer goes behind
the scenes of the epic final season
before I get actually I'll just get into
this and then I'll ask you the question
I want to ask you because you're such
like a ride-or-die Stan right and I want
to know like though your top five in
order of like people or groups that like
like I know Taylor Swift oh people that
I love okay yeah ariana grande no she's
not in there what yeah well we'll talk
about it Game of Thrones may be almost
over but HBO was gearing up for one
final ride for fans of its massive hit
show Wow like help me the last watch is
a two-hour documentary about the making
of the show's eighth and final season
and going by the trailer it looks like
it will go in depth with the show's
creators to explain how they brought
Thrones to an epic conclusion as well as
what the experience is meant for those
who have spent years making the biggest
show on television the last watch airs
on May 26 I mean I need this just
because I'm dirt Sunday night like I'm
gonna truly go into like a depression
over the end of Game of Thrones so like
this will keep me going for another week
also the trailer looks like so sweet
it's so many people talking about like
what the show has meant to them like
someone says like this show saved my
life yeah
remember I read a story I think it was a
woman who played Roz or one of the
prostitutes on the show was actually
like um doing that in real life and then
she got this opportunity to be on the
show and like this show like saved her
life
that's insane I don't recall it was Ross
specifically but it was a game with rose
actress who like was played someone in a
brothel and that was what she was doing
did you watch the game revealed for this
past episode yeah but it was the short
one no the game revealed it was 35
minutes oh no no no I just watched it
inside the episode oh my god it was so
crazy so they rebuilt like King's
Landing like how you know it's usually
in like Croatia but because it was gonna
be destroyed they literally rebuilt the
entire thing in a parking lot but they
rebuilt it already destroyed on the
inside and then just like painted over
to make it look legitimate it's the
craziest thing ever like if you watch
this whole thing how they did it oh my
god is one you know that they use real
fire they they really they really lit
people on fire it was the crazy saying
they put them in like all these specific
things that are covered in all the SEPA
blah and they light them on fire and
then right after they shoot the scene
you see - what it's 26 people who are
lit on fire and so you see 26 other
people run to them with fire
extinguishers and put them out like it's
not a bit of snake which is so crazy
that's so crazy I wouldn't want to watch
out anytime soon just because like I
don't want to know how the sauce gets
made you know like but that that the
documentary kind of looks like just a
longer version of that always ya know
like the green screens and and the
people who work on this show I mean
it'll be like when we watch feeding the
beast they show how they made like that
sake time right is interesting it's not
gonna like change my life but what they
say in the documentary is like each
episode of this season is um it's a
feature film it is though I think that
every time I watch it took oh i'm
sitting down to watch movie it's an hour
and a half uh-huh like the that battle
with the white walkers it's like that
was a full movie that was a full moon I
mean like it was 15 million dollars like
that's more than most like movies get
for budget right which is just so crazy
and they're turning it out every week I
mean I guess they did take a year and a
half to do it but that's okay yeah it's
it's incredible so many top five your
top five Taylor okay let me first name
them and then maybe I'll rank them just
so I can get them okay yeah Taylor
Lou Combs Olivia culpo
oh it's just like people that I let you
stand that you will never no matter what
they do like you will be I don't think
Olivia culpo stop by like I love her so
much but like I don't know okay um Hugh
Jackman okay Oh Tim McGraw Tim McGraw
except like he's just kind of fallen off
the face of the earth but I'm still here
for him yeah but he's just there's not
like there's not much for you to
participate or defend yeah okay
and think of music Ari you were so in
the class I'm not obsessed with her it's
just like I really like her music and
then like the more or less - it's a kind
of trash but in a good way you know what
somebody is I'm actually like the
opposite it's like I love her as a
person I love her style I love
everything about her except sometimes
her music like I loved her sing like
thank you next seven rings obsessed but
like the stuff that makes up her albums
like really just doesn't do it for me
that's there no like she's definitely
not someone like if she did something
like wrong like I could easily flip Oh
for me Kim Kardashian and Kylie oh but
you're not like Kim I'm not obsessed
with Kim but like I'm obsessed with Kim
but I'm not like obsessed with yem I
don't know I can't think about it I feel
like I'm like weirdly obsessed with a
lot of things I just like it could also
be a show that it's like no matter what
they do dynasty maybe Fallon Carrington
for you Liz Gillies like I literally
love her if I think it more I don't know
it's just like
Riverdale anyone from Riverdale know
that they Krauss if it never Mendes know
if they did me wrong like I'm trying to
think of like something that I'm like
blindly loyal to like if Lou combs
killed someone like I defend him
yes I know you would yeah like in a
heartbeat I'm trying to think whose this
is for me but I'm not as like I mean I
guess I'm blindly loyal to Kim - Kylie -
ah - I can't - oh I can't now like music
who do I just
Kelly Clarkson oh you are blindly loyal
to Kelly Clarkson I am I really am and
this like artists that I love
there's so many that I like truly true
blindly loyal to one direction and also
Kacey Musgraves yeah yeah arey styles
for you oh [ __ ] yeah no I'm what I'm
very loyal to one direction - Zayn like
extremely yes like the second that they
get back together like I'm totally okay
so recap Vanderpump rules Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
um the Erika Jayne concert was like so
incredible and so lit but here's my
question and this would be a better
question for Claudia because she's like
in the touring space but what Erika
Jayne does and like is only something
that also like countess LuAnn has done -
which is really brain like the extract
the housewives experience - life via
show on tour right and it's like LuAnn
does so many shows and I think like
bigger venues and I wonder why Erika I
understand why she might not do so many
shows because like it really is taxing
and like she has like her life in LA and
like I think she's really more strategic
about it but I feel like she could be
playing like even bigger venues but
whatever
yeah I last caught me attack anyway yeah
her show like looks so fun and so
amazing and she was such a trooper and
her husband came do you know about her
Nathan and he's like an older man he was
just like he's her biggest fan I guess
when she started being Erika Jayne was
before she was a housewife I remember
reading it in her book and like she was
you know like in her like late 30s and
she just like wanted to like perform and
like a creative outlet and he like
really bankrolled the whole thing and
now and so she was able to get like the
best creative directors like the best
answers best hair makeup costumes and
now like Erika Jayne makes money on her
own so it's better but like him being
able to watch her show and like this was
really something that like and she says
like it's all because of Tom Girardi and
he was the smile on his face like he was
so so cute and like everyone likes to
question their marriage but like to me
they look so happy and if you read her
book like you will have no questions
like they just they work you know what
so then camille Grammer goes to Lisa
Vanderpump's house and she is saying one
thing to Lisa and then her confessional
is playing and she's such like she is
such a [ __ ] liar Camille like she is
just so two-faced it's crazy she really
talked out the side of her mouth and
then
Savannah pump it says like 24 hours
later she's going to had a lie detector
test to like ask if she makes these
stories to Radar Online which is just so
crazy and so stupid and like Kyle
Richards tweeted like who what type of
person goes to these lengths to prove
something like yeah you know it's so
fishy I can't but I will say I love her
new kitchen and I didn't need to watch
the remodeling of it because like I
don't even watch those sorts of like
home shows even with HGTV but the end
result it's like all white marble with
silver finishes and then I'm like there
was pink cleany
like cassoulet dish teapot so it's like
touches of pink clean white marble with
silver and pink lien it was perfect that
is Lisa Vanderpump and now when you look
at her ol kitchen she literally had like
a a restaurant kitchen it was weird it's
like all metal but it's so beautiful so
I'm glad we were able to see that I
really I'm still team everyone else but
like the show was making it really
difficult and now I'm feeling like you
know they're really putting so many
cards and like the chips are stacked for
Lisa Danner back yeah to like have an
acute like to be able to talk her way
out of it and it's just frustrating that
is right you know I thought this was
gonna be the time we got taken down but
she'll never be taken down just because
she has such a big stake in Bravo like
they wouldn't do that
logistically makes no sense I know but I
had hope for a second but now I have no
hope 11:11 make a wish I wish for world
peace that's right Bachelorette so I
watched and I first three minutes and I
called Jackie and I was like Jackie you
have to watch because like she's just so
cute and like her whole motto is like
you know how bad cuz she's like I'm
doing the damn thing she's like I'm just
a normal girl trying to be the
Bachelorette like I'm nothing special
like I'm just like trying to figure it
out and she's like doing the promos of
her like walking in the field and she's
like I have no idea what I'm doing she's
like I don't know dude my hands it
wasn't like fake and she was trying to
be relatable like she genuinely had no
idea what to do and I felt that because
then you know you're taking a photo like
you don't know what to do with your
hands like I get it you're welcome to
her fields whatever so it was just like
oh she's so cute and then she's like is
beautiful she looked great and they she
actually has really great style even on
when she was on yes in season she was
dressing herself there were a few things
that I literally wanted to buy from her
wearing them on the show now she has a
stylist but like I actually I mean I
loved Becca
she had horrible style so for that
reason maybe but keep going I'm so good
they brought Demi on okay in the
beginning her Demi and Katie and they
were sitting in like a surveillance
truck like watching Hannah with the boys
and like making all these comments there
was just like some [ __ ] or whatever
and Demi was like that guy's a douche
and then like he would say something and
and she was like he's not my type but
like she seems to be into it it's just
like a funny like little quirky thing
and then she found out that someone had
a girlfriend and so she like went to
take him down and so she told Hannah and
Hannah P was like such a savage about it
like she wasn't even like trying to be
nice she was like she literally was like
get to steppin like get out of here I'm
like he wasn't walking fast enough for
her and she was like come on let's go
like a dog like pushing him out of the
house it was just like very like well
done and like real and then there's so
many cute guys honestly like very cute
guys and he stand out there's one was
for me Peter the pilot Peter the pilot
is so cute
and I think he makes it far based off of
the previews but then there's just like
so many cute guys to get her first
impression Rose no this guy Luke got our
first impression rose and most of the
bachelorettes end up with their first
impression the last he's a villain like
I know it but then I can kind of I could
kind of tell based off of the preview
because they were like trying to hide it
because I think he makes it sort of far
and then like the switch type of thing
but there's absolutely no way he wins
he's literally like just he his thing
was that he was in the shower and he
realized that he wasn't the man that he
saw Jesus in the shower and he realized
he wasn't the man he was supposed to be
so he changed okay
that was the story and she fell for it -
that was his story like but why did she
give him the rock in the pre in his life
coach they smooch because she gave him
the first she actually smooch I think
like three guys okay and she even the
first impression rose because he kept
stealing her so I think she's got the
most time with her and then she was so
mad about the whole girlfriend thing
that she went off on her own to like
like take a breath and he like followed
her out I was like are you okay and she
was like I'm so cold and like he didn't
give her her jacket like Twitter
obviously it was like oh my little
things but it was shirt like she was
freezing your way or see Jack and she's
in a spaghetti strap dress like why not
give her your coat that is
[ __ ] that yeah right um what else anyone
like good for you think it's gonna be
good for Paradise I'll still watch
peridot there's definitely gonna be good
good guys for Paradise just because a
lot of them like just look like hot nice
bod like paradise vibe but she also does
seem to have a lot of them are like
Southern cuz like she's from Alabama
like I think there was like four guys
who were from like Birmingham Montgomery
Alabama so no I think I have faith in
the I I think this is gonna actually be
a great season I just really really like
her like more so than I'd like to Becca
I don't know not more than I liked
Rachel but like whatever I think she was
a great choice honestly and like I was
saying if it was Hannah gee like it
would be mad boring so you think because
we never got to see how Angie's
personality and I think there's a lot
more there maybe but this one like she
has so much person who is Hannah Jean
I'm just I mean you say that in the
first three minutes it's it's a great
chance to change show so maybe I'll give
it the first three minutes it's just it
felt very much like it wasn't like so
edited like they and there was this part
like right after she met everyone she
was about to go into the like the
cocktail party that she just like
snapped off to the side and started
praying and she was like give me the
strength to like be smart to like all
this stuff and they like kept it in and
it was like so nice I just like it seems
very different and it didn't seem very
spiritual she has she loves she's but
like also Luke and his shower yeah
because she loves Jesus said I guess
that made for automatic not like Jesus
lovers - yeah got it but no I think it's
like it just seems not as edited and
like planned out maybe I don't know like
what will happen but I feel like she's
not there for that kind of like garbage
mm-hmm so we'll see but I very much
enjoyed it okay
maybe I'll try it but like it's just
because now I've said so many times I'm
not gonna watch and now the next time I
say if he won't believe me I'm like the
girl who never made sense for you not to
watch this one cuz like this one I like
I feel like we knew was gonna be good
like if it did what do you see her after
the final rose yeah but like I would any
like I'll be like that too
like that's a scary look but no I mean
just watch you can watch the first
episode if you don't like it then then
don't watch anymore - now we're half of
your time
we'll see I mean
I miss precious counselors and watch it
tomorrow because there's no show yeah
tomorrow will be a podcast only episode
from across the pond in Asia quiet will
be recording I'm Claudia deja yeah so
thank you all for tuning in anything
else that you that you have to say about
anything you've watched or any other
thoughts no okay go study for your final
snitch you got to get that degree I know
I'm working on it I'm so excited I need
to put a countdown on my phone of like
snitch or countdown like the countdown
thing on Instagram stories until
snitches graduation cuz then I'll also
have it to be able to say yeah exactly
okay cool I'll do that and then I'll put
a filter on it with Jackie O Flo not a
filter preset I always keep confusing
like you know I agree set is a failed a
very good one but I never liked it
actually technically isn't but I keep
saying like filter because to me it's
like the changing of a photo as a filter
but I know I'm confusing other people
who don't know the difference between a
preset and the filter if you have preset
questions I have a whole Q&A up at my
Instagram story and like I think it's
pretty except planetory my friends who
like barely used Instagram like who
wouldn't know what a priest I was I've
hit them in the face like wanted to
support me so they got my presets and
watch my tutorials and they are changed
people and so like I'm so happy for that
so head to Jackie O Flo FL o w comm to
get your preset packs there's indoor
presets outdoor presets people have
asked me like can use indoor for outdoor
and outdoor and indoor yes of course you
can there's no rules when it comes to
presets just the outdoor pack is like
made for natural light so they it
doesn't really correct too much light
adds to it whereas indoor like there's
much more work to be done so like the
indoor presets are more impactful but
you can get all ten fifty dollars five
bucks a preset it's good stuff so head
on over there and I think you will think
we haven't seen really positive glowing
reviews no it's like there's nothing not
to like about that there's just so fun
and it's exactly what you need if you're
not trying to like have like the grainy
like orange ugly photos yeah like so
much like cream and white and you know
what like that that is a vibe and it is
spoken for by many a blogger you know go
Swagger's don't have what you like your
flow right they don't want you and they
have
and that's cool but for those of us who
just want like fun photos full of color
and full of life that'll just be like
premium as hell and make for like a fun
vibrant it's Aramco it's very campy
it'll be super camp it'll be so good for
campos but like in all senses of the
word it's just like extra Thea and fun
so jackieo flow dot-com thank you
everyone for tuning in everyone who's
buying my presets we love ya bye bye
you